gets it inside to embiid working on hood  a flurry of moves  short gets his own to the deck he goes  trying to get a timeout instead it'll be  a jump ball  [Applause]  great effort there all parties  so they'll jump it with joel embiid  [Music]  boy look at that opening up a gash  the left eye of innis canner  [Applause]  socano that looks like that is going to  require stitches  and with a minute 18 left on his way  back  to the locker room let's see who got it  was his own teammate  friendly fire there from robert  covington on the left eye  man  [Applause]  ouch  [Applause]  for that  [Music]  [Applause]  am i my brother's keeper my goodness his  own guy got him though  this is what cantor  had done obviously i can't count them  all reggie but that looks like  five stitches in there to close  [Applause]  [Music]  good work here's canner springs free and  scores the layup  nice place drawn up on the inbounds  easy